thank you so much for staying with us
here at 4 30. I'm Christian casadas I'm
Kirsten Joyce we are nearing the tail
end of what metro police consider the
100 deadliest days of traffic related
fatalities that time period is Memorial
Day to Labor Day that's right well this
year there have been 36
pedestrian-related fatalities 27 of them
the pedestrians fault Jeremy J Ford is
at lamb and Boulder Highway where Metro
Police addressed the issue
with the recent increase of pedestrian
versus motor vehicle accidents across
the Valley Metro has a message for both
drivers and pedestrians don't rely on
pedestrian signals just because the
signal turns green and gives you the
opportunity to walk out there does not
mean that it's safe to do so Lieutenant
Daryl Rhodes with Metro's traffic Bureau
has these rules for pedestrians when you
come to the curb and you're getting
ready to cross stop
look both ways it's something that we've
learned since elementary school he's
also asking those who walk to make eye
contact with drivers and stay within the
crosswalk if you step out in the traffic
you don't know if you don't get hit or
not Linda Jordan says she feels it's her
responsibility to pay attention because
most drivers tend to be distracted and
drive too fast you shouldn't be driving
like that on the street with old people
oldest and he can't get across the
street like that we can't run no more
and Metro is asking drivers to stop
driving impaired make sure that when
you're driving that vehicle you're
paying attention to what's going on out
there it's the slightest bit of
circumstances can change turning your
vehicle into a deadly weapon Jeremy J
Ford 8 News Now
Jeremy thank you for that well so far
this year there have been more than 90
traffic related fatalities in Metro
police's jurisdiction now the department
says it will continue to work pedestrian
safety in high traffic areas